من اربعه اشهر تابع العرب تفاصيل الخلاف
اللي صار بين الفنانين مريم فارس وفارس
كرم واللي وصل للاسف للشتاء والقضاء وفي
اكتوبر تم استدعاء فارس كرم والتحقيق معه
وتركه بضمان محل اقامته وبعد ما تعهد بعدم
التعرض لها واليوم بيتفاعل لكم هنعرض لكم
حصريا المستندات الرسميه اللي بتتضمن
تفاصيل الدعوه واقوال فارس كرم الازمه
بدات في الاعلام بكلام عن اعتراض فارس على
صوره بوستر لحفل بيجمع الفنانين في
السعوديه وحجم صوره فارس مقارنه بصوره
مريام ميريام وقتها طلعت وضحت وقالت انه
فارس زينه الشباب وانه هي ما لها دخل
بالبوستر يعني
انا
ما بحب انه ينخلق خلافات مانا موجوده فارس
خيره الشباب وانا بحبه كثير والله يوفقه
يمكن زعل من حجم الصوره بس بالنهايه ولا
انا ولا فارس من قرر في الشركه هي اللي
عملت الحفله وفي في اداره جايه فوق الشركه
يا اللي هي الترفيه بالسعوديه وكلنا بنعرف
هن بقرروا كيف تكون احجم الصور مش
لكن فارس كرم ردوا كان مختلف
شفنا صوره الاعلان بجده انت ميريام فارس
اصغر شويه او فيها حلوه وصغيره الشباب
[موسيقى]
حبيب قلبي
مو حرزانه وعيب اللي صار ووضحت انه هي
اختارته لمشاركه الحفل من بين عده فنانين
فارس ما سكتوا بالعكس تمادى ووصل الموضوع
لقمه ولمن غرد التغريده اللي شايفينها
امامكم الان وفيها كلام غير قابل للعرض
وحتى اضطرينا انه نغطيه
تمام هذا الكلام مريام فارس وعدد باللجوء
للقضاء على شان تجيب حقها وبالفعل هذا
اللي سوته فالدعوه تقدمته في زمن قياسي تم
النظر فيها بالنظر طبعا لانه تحولت
الموضوع كل القصه هذه كلها تحولت لقضيه
راي عام فالانتقادات نزلت على فارس كرم من
كل جيهان مو بس من محبين ميريام لكن كمان
خاصه من اللي اعتبره وكلامه اهانه لكل
النساء مو بس مريام والنجوم للشتم المراه
بشرفها دائما انه هذه الطريقه اللي على
طول نشتمها بشرفها في اي خلاف يصير مع اي
امراه
احنا في تفاعلكم مثل ما قلنا لكم مشاهدينا
معانا اليوم حصريا المستندات الرسميه اللي
بتبين تفاصيل الدعوه اللي رفعتها ميريام
فارس ضد فارس كرم ومعاها تفاصيل استدعاء
والكلام اللي قاله امام القاضي ومثل ما
شايفين امامكم اعترف باللي قالوا وفي اول
القاضي الجزائري مثل ما شايفين امامكم
ادعى بحق فارس كرم وهذا يعني انه قاضي
التحقيق بما انه احاله القضيه للمحكمه
فمعناها انه شاف في اعتداء على مريام هذا
غير طبعا انه القضاء الزم بعدم التعرض لها
واشبر انه يحذف التغريده هذا كله انتصار
لمريام فارس ضد فارس كرم الاستهان من اول
كثير بموضوع لجوءها للقضاء
بصراحه المستندات كان فيها تفصيله ثانيه
لفتتنا جدا فعند سؤال فارس كرم في التحقيق
عن التغريده اعترف ان هو اللي كاتبها لكن
تبريره كان ملفت فقال انه بالشتيمه اللي
كتبها ما كان يقصد اهانه مريام كامراه
وانما كان قصده بس انها ثرثاره ولئيمه
انا سمعت تفسيرات كثير كلام بس الكلمه هذه
اكيد لا تعني قيمه بس يعني بس انه بس عشان
يعني بس عشان الواحد يعني كل واضح يعني
طيب
نقول كلمه تلحق صراحه طيب قدام هذه
الوثائق ما قدرنا ما نتذكر ظهور فارس»
انا بدي اياها تروح على القضاء
لحتى تعرفيه حجمها لقد وين راحت قدامي
ولا
هيجيبوا لك اياهن بده ياخذوني
مثل هذا نحن التفاعلكم تواصلنا مع ميريام
وطلبنا تعليق منها وهي اكتفت بانه تقول
انها وعدت الناس انه تجيب حقها وحق كل
الستات وفات بوعدها وانه حقها رجع لها
عموما نحن ترى من اول يوم دونا فيها هذه
القصه واحنا بنقول وبناكد انه فارس كلم
فارس كرم عفوا له حق الرد تماما وبنرجع
اليوم وبناكد على هذا الكلام وبنقول انه
حق الرد تماما وانه صراحه حتى نحن كثير
حابين نستفسر على جزئيه الثرثاره ولا قيمه
وربطها بالكلمه هذه كثير جزئيه مهمه حابين
نعرفها اكثر منه يعني